foreign
in the summer of 2002 the director of
the British intelligence agency MI6
Richard dearlove traveled to Washington
DC to meet with the director of the CIA
George Tennant the topic of the meeting
was Iraq and its leader Saddam Hussein
in the meeting the CIA director shared
classified information with his British
counterpart who then traveled back to
London to 10 Downing Street the home of
the Prime Minister Tony Blair
gearlov told his prime minister
everything about what was really
happening behind the scenes in the
United States how the U.S was planning
to invade Iraq no matter what it was a
highly classified meeting but notes were
taken and classified and put into a memo
that memo was later leaked to British
author and journalist Michael Smith who
published it in 2005. and that's what
we're looking at a secret meeting and
the memo It produced meant only for the
eyes of top British officials it was an
explosive leak what we see is that dear
love tells his prime minister everything
he heard in Washington a few days
earlier and that this was a very
different story than the one the Bush
Administration was telling to the public
that an American invasion was inevitable
that Bush's people were fixated on
removing Saddam Hussein from Power no
matter what and that the U.S government
was blatantly cooking up Intel and facts
to help sell their invasion this
document shows us how power really works
in our world how a small group of people
decided to topple a dictator to occupy a
country and then invented a story to
support their plan it was a false story
but it helped them sell a horrifying War
it's a story that is revealed in detail
by the Downing Street memo
[Music]
necessary
hey we are interrupting the programming
for a commercial break that's how we're
able to make videos and do all of this
because we have sponsors if you're a
long time viewer of the channel you will
know that I am a giant fan of therapy
Professional Therapy with a professional
therapist I went because I felt like I
wanted to understand my mind better I
wanted to understand some of my demons
better been doing it for three years and
it has reshaped the way that I see the
world the sponsor of today's video is
betterhelp who is a company that is
trying to make therapy more accessible
using technology usually when you try to
find a therapist you call around at
least here in the United States to like
see if your insurance works and if
there's availability and you go sit in
an office with better help you sign up
and you fill out a questionnaire and
then betterhelp matches you with
somebody in their massive network of
licensed therapists there's like tens of
thousands of people in this network and
they will match you with somebody and
unlike the traditional way you can be
communicating with a therapist in as
little as like 48 hours which is
mind-blowing for those of us who have
gone the traditional way before if you
don't like your therapist you can switch
for free and choose somebody else in
their massive network if you're not
interested in like a video call you can
just do it over text if that's how you
prefer to communicate the point is that
learning to trust and communicate with a
professional can have huge benefits on
your life and better help tries to make
it a more frictionless process for you
to get connected with a good therapist
and start changing your life with
therapy we live in a time where therapy
is more and more normalized and I love
that and I love that better help is
working hard to get people into therapy
there's a link in my description it's
betterhelp.com Johnny Harris when you
click the link it helps support the
channel but it also gets you in on 10
off your first month so you can try it
out at a discount and see if it's a good
fit for you for me therapy took a few
months to develop that trust and develop
an understanding of how it was working
in my life so you can try it out and see
if it has that same effect for you and
again you can cancel anytime if you feel
like it isn't a good fit for you thank
you better help for sponsoring today's
video and with that let's get back into
it with the Downing Street memo
on September the 11th enemies of Freedom
committed an act of war against our
country the United States military has
begun strikes against al Qaeda terrorist
training camps in Afghanistan let's
start by looking at another document
from the fall of 2001 when deputy
secretary of defense Paul wolfowitz
created this memo for his boss Donald
Rumsfeld the secretary of defense this
was just 10 weeks after the attacks that
changed the course of history but this
document wasn't about that it was about
Iraq a country that had nothing to do
with 9 11. Rumsfeld reviewed the
document before meeting with an army
General he marked it up with his notes
giving us insight into what the
secretary of defense of the United
States was really thinking about after 9
11. how this group of military leaders
were set on quote building momentum to
topple Iraq's dictator Saddam Hussein to
decapitate the government a government
that was no longer useful to them Saddam
Hussein had been a useful client to the
United States especially in the 80s when
he was waging a war against Iran an
enemy of the United States but those
days were now over Saddam had turned
into just a troublemaker in the region
creating instability that could threaten
the US's easy access to oil two hours
ago Allied Air Forces began an attack on
Military Targets in Iraq and Kuwait this
conflict started August 2nd when the
dictator of Iraq invaded a small and
helpless neighbor and in many ways Iraq
was an old mess in need of cleaning up a
mess that bush senior had failed to
resolve during the first Gulf War Iraq
was supposed to disarm itself after that
war but had kicked out the U.N weapons
inspector teams
but that wasn't the main reason why
right after 9 11 these guys were talking
about invading Iraq a bigger reason is
that these leaders wanted to remind the
world who the global superpower was they
needed to after being brutally attacked
on their own soil a non-us-friendly
regime like Iraq couldn't be allowed to
stand in a post-9 11 world or in the
words of Rumsfeld himself hours after
the towers fell quote we need to bomb
something else to show that we're big
and strong and not going to be pushed
around
a rock and its leader was that something
else
and now Bush and his advisors were
looking at a plan to make it a reality
but how to start the war could they tie
Saddam Hussein to something that
Americans feared like 911 or Anthrax or
could they tell a story about weapons of
mass destruction what other countries
could they bring in to support their
Invasion and of course the most
important consideration rumsfield jots
it here at the end they would need an
influence campaign they would need to
sell the war and when should they begin
how about right away
Iraq continues to flaunt its hostility
toward America and to support Terror
three months later the president was
telling the world that Iraq was one of a
group of evil countries that the U.S
must oppose in the global fight against
good and evil States like these
constitute an axis of Evil the price of
indifference would be catastrophic by
the summer of 2002 this idea that Bush's
advisors had scratched down after 9 11
was developing into an official policy
that handwritten influence campaign to
sell the war was now in full swing there
is no doubt that Saddam Hussein now has
weapons of mass destruction the Iraqi
regime has been free to pursue the
development of weapons of mass
destruction we know they have weapons of
mass destruction there isn't any debate
about it and this is exactly what the
head of MI6 told Prime Minister Tony
Blair at his house in the summer of 2002
after meeting with the CIA in Washington
it's what we see in the Downing Street
memo that there was a perceptible shift
in attitude in Washington and that the
U.S invasion of Iraq was now seen as
inevitable and that they were now fixing
intelligence around a decision that they
had already made and that the U.S wasn't
really planning to work with the UN they
didn't want weapons inspections or
getting U.N approval for military force
and crucially the head of the MI6 tells
the Prime Minister that these bush
people aren't really thinking much about
the aftermath of such an invasion
what is inevitable is not regime change
it is disarmament of weapons of mass
destruction
this memo wasn't supposed to be seen by
anyone but just a few and that's why we
can learn from it it serves as one of
the most potent pieces of evidence that
the Bush Administration was maneuvering
two very different stories their private
story about the need to remove a
dictator to project U.S power which was
in stark contrast to the public story
that they had to tell to sell the
invasion their influence campaign any
country on the face of the Earth with an
active intelligence program knows that
Iraq has weapons of mass destruction
because they knew that if they were
really going to sell this war they would
need to convince not only the American
public but also Congress and at least
partially the International Community
what we learn in the Downing Street memo
is that they had settled on two main
focus points for their story that Iraq
has weapons of mass destruction and that
they're also working with the
masterminds of 9 11. not long after this
meeting between MI6 and the CIA Bush and
his allies ramp up their influence
campaign to sell their War
we've learned that Iraq has trained Al
Qaeda members in bomb making poisons and
deadly gases the sales pitches to the
American people for an invasion of Iraq
were made with absolute certainty
certainty that Iraq had wmds he had
agreed and the U.N a degree that they
would he would not have a wmd program we
know he does have one certainty that
they wanted to use them against
Americans and American Allies simply
stated
there is no doubt that Saddam Hussein
now has weapons of mass destruction that
he is amassing them to use against our
friends against our allies and against
us certainty that Iraq was harboring
terrorists and Al-Qaeda terrorists
escaped from Afghanistan and are known
to be in Iraq and certainty that Iraq
was working on obtaining nuclear weapons
and Iraq's state-controlled media has
reported numerous meetings between
Saddam Hussein and his nuclear
scientists leaving little doubt about
his continued appetite
for these weapons and these speeches
were working by the fall of 2002
Americans were in favor of an invasion
of Iraq by just a narrow majority but
there was just one problem that all of
these statements were lies
indeed this was already known in the
secret rooms of Downing street that the
U.S was fixing their facts and their
Intel to match their already made
decision Iraq's supposed links to
Al-Qaeda were based on one interrogation
of a guy whose testimony lacked quote
specific details and who was
intentionally lying about it to mislead
his interrogators Bush and his allies
knew this it was clearly documented back
in February of 2002 and yet publicly the
scary story about Al Qaeda being in Iraq
continued to be sold by Bush and his
people the Iraqi regime has plotted to
develop Anthrax nerve gas and nuclear
weapons for over a decade the case for
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq was
equally thin and Senior officials knew
it like in September 2002 When Donald
Rumsfeld received this report from The
Joint Chiefs assessing what real
evidence there actually was for wmd in
Iraq the report is shockingly honest and
it says that the conclusion that Saddam
has wmd quote relied heavily on analytic
assumptions and judgments rather than
hard evidence that's word solid for it
was speculation and conjecture the
report goes on to say that they didn't
have anything solid on nuclear weapons
related facilities and concludes that
they don't know of any facilities where
Saddam may be producing or testing
biological weapons and so we know now
that they had almost no evidence for
their story about why the U.S should
invade Iraq and yet even knowing this
they kept selling the same story
convincing the American people there's
no doubt in my mind he wants to have a
nuclear weapon and he's got some
capacity wherever threats are forming
against our country we will respond but
they couldn't go on like this forever
they knew that if they were really going
to sell this war they were going to need
to show real convincing evidence not to
the people but to Congress
and this is where we get another
instance of fixing the intelligence to
fit the policy it came in September 2002
when President Bush asks Congress to
give him the authority to invade Iraq in
response Senate leaders requested an
immediate National Intelligence estimate
which is a report from the entire
intelligence Community meant to help
Congress make informed decisions this
could be really bad for Bush and his
allies so he and the CIA get hard at
work pulling together a report that fits
their story intelligence to back up all
their public statements and speeches
they come out with this highly redacted
report that they deliver in October of
2002 the report makes some very strong
claims they claim that Iraq has been
building more wmd that they have
chemical and biological weapons and that
they will have a nuclear weapon during
this decade and to Congressional leaders
this appeared Rock Solid here was the
entire intelligence Community coming
together saying that Iraq had horrific
weapons and that they wanted to get more
Saddam Hussein has composed a Scarlet
chapter of Terror our only responsible
option is to confront this threat before
Americans die there is no such thing is
a Democrat or Republican War so in that
same month based on this report and all
of these public speeches Congress gives
the green light for war
but this National Intelligence estimate
was deeply flawed it was a perfect
example of the fixed intelligence
described in the Downing Street memo it
was put together in less than a month
totally rushed the report had been
plagued by groupthink and directed by
political pressure with the Bush
Administration pushing analysts to
deliver a report that matched their
conclusions that they had already come
to months earlier and they did this
using very old intelligence the CIA
hadn't had any human assets on the
ground for years so their report wasn't
even based off of anything after 1998
but it didn't matter Bush and his allies
had successfully sold the war to
Congress and the American people but
there was one last hurdle it was the
International Community which would mean
they would have to face the UN process
that they apparently had no patience for
Iraq has answered a decade of U.N
demands with a decade of defiance so
it's November 2002 and in response to
the rising tensions between Iraq and the
U.S the U.N security Council passes this
resolution 1441. it was a measure that
was meant to give Iraq a final
opportunity to comply with weapons
inspections to show the world that they
had fully disarmed and had no weapons of
mass destruction Bush and his allies saw
this as an opportunity if they could
somehow show that Iraq wasn't complying
with this new inspection process this
resolution implied that they would be
justified in invading the country their
long-desired War would be on
but they had a problem which is that
Iraq and Saddam Hussein were complying
with the weapons inspections over the
course of four months un weapons
inspectors searched Iraq from top to
bottom they were led by Hans Blix the
former head of the international atomic
energy agency they conducted over 900
inspections at over 500 locations
and they didn't find anything no wmd no
biological weapons no nuclear weapons
programs Iraq has on the whole
cooperated rather well access has been
provided to all Sites we have wanted to
inspect universities military bases
presidential sites and private
residences Hans Blix did find two things
that were important first they did find
some ballistic missiles that the UN says
have an effective range that makes them
illegal so they would need to be
destroyed by Iraq and second there were
some chemical weapons that the Iraqi
regime said cannot be accounted for but
Blix insists that this does not mean
that they have these weapons it just
means that they need more time to work
out the accounting situation but this
error was exactly what the bush Circle
needed to justify their Invasion I call
now on the distinguished secretary of
state of the United States of America
they sent their most respected cabinet
member to the UN Secretary of State
Colin Powell he came equipped with
photos of what he says are mobile
weapons facilities Sodom Hussein and his
regime are concealing their efforts to
produce more weapons of mass destruction
he plays tapes that he says prove that
the Iraqis are hiding their weapons we
evacuated everything to make sure it was
not around when the inspectors showed up
and then he says that this is solid
evidence that shows that Iraq is
violating the U.N resolution that told
them to disarm this whole thing
contradicts what the U.N weapons
inspectors had found in their hundreds
and hundreds of inspections they
bulldozed the process and say they have
justification to invade my colleagues we
have an obligation to see that
our resolutions are complied with
they've got the American public on board
they've got Congress on board and now
the UK is in lockstep this is the time
for this house to show that we will
stand up for what we know to be right
to show that we will confront the
tyrannies and dictatorships and
terrorists who put our way of life at
risk the Bush Administration abandons
the UN process and that March his people
do what they set out to do 18 months
earlier when they were looking for
something else to bomb
show who's really in charge on the world
stage my fellow citizens American and
Coalition forces are in the early stages
of military operations to disarm Iraq to
free its people and to defend the world
from grave danger America faces an enemy
has no regard for conventions of war or
rules of morality
foreign
[Music]
Bush's War took the life of an estimated
half million Iraqis and thousands more
who fought for their country and over
the course of a decade occupying Iraq no
weapons were found no nuclear facilities
no mobile weapons labs in fact it seemed
like Iraq had dismantled its nuclear
program back in 1991 and the rest of its
chemical and biological weapons just a
few years later
after the invasion the U.S never allowed
the UN inspectors back into the country
to help with their search the US would
never find a way to link the Iraqi
regime to Al-Qaeda or to Anthrax Colin
Powell the Secretary of State who played
a major role in selling this war to the
International Community would later say
that he regrets his part in starting the
War I deeply regret some of the
information I presented which was
multi-source was wrong Hans Blix the
chief weapons inspector for the UN would
comment later that year that it is sort
of fascinating that you can have 100
certainty about weapons of mass
destruction action and zero certainty
about where they are
we may never know what was in the heart
and minds of these senior leaders
whether they truly believed their own
lies whether they felt justified in the
choices they made but what we can learn
from this story is how these leaders
behaved when they thought no one was
watching when they thought they could
tell a compelling story to the public
while having a totally different set of
motivations and how with enough fear and
enough deception you can lead an entire
Society into an unprovoked war changing
the course of history in the process
our economy is in recession
and the Civilized World faces
unprecedented dangers
yet the state of our Union has never
been stronger
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign